what was it like for you to become a
tick-tock phenomenon could you have ever
imagined that would happen
we didn't really know what tick-tock was
tick-tock was some new [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying when nobody
even owned tick-tock
you know what i'm saying we really was
just surprised what it was in the
streets
[Music]
what's the deal this photo dude you
watching on the rocks
freedom boys with my boy
[Music]
these two was made by waffy the newest
but this the original
it was made by gary in detroit this is
my first train period
this one right here i had just came home
from jail
and my home my homie had two of them i
think
and he like you know i was saying don't
nobody else got one but me
[Music]
everybody call me doggy so i
i thought i'd get this i got my son
one too yeah
some cool probably like 20 something
25 something like that
um cmg you see i got the dog on there
i got this from guy i think last year
yeah he gave us all one of these
a few of them had custom bills on there
the man had the dog on her so yeah
i appreciate this i met up at a concert
in detroit
i had went to one his concert before but
i didn't meet him though
so this time he had one like uh
little sisters and he asked me like
you know what i'm saying you're like
you want to come out and perform i'm
like hell yeah
he brought me out and we just kicked it
after that
and he like you know that's how i want
to [ __ ] with you
and that's how that was how'd you first
link up with little baby
i heard that when you guys first met he
didn't even know that he rapped yeah
when we first met
he was in uh l.a you know we we're just
kidding
shooting dice gown and me and he'll just
start [ __ ] around on the song
i had to delay the intro part of it and
the next day
he sent me sent me it back with his
first his two verses and the hook on
there
and uh he like you gotta get back on you
like you gotta finish it
you know i'm saying it's gonna be one on
one and i flew to atlanta
and i finished it and it was one-on-one
[Music]
just a uh phobia i had a name
my name tag on her said doug
though from icebox just something you
know i'm saying
cool two-time rose and white
i think i got this two years ago
and then this phobia man sid got these
i just bought it just the bad
like 25 being with the diamond lean
look cool son i [ __ ] with god
i [ __ ] youngster
my homeboy twin before he went to jail
he had some you know what i'm saying
had some prezzies he had two-tone patty
he had cuban he had diamond links like
he turned me on a diamond
it's the presidential role
day date i think this probably was my
first presidential
it was my first presidential i got this
from new york
i got this from avianne i really
traded a watch baby gave me
for this that's how i got this it's like
50
50 60 i bought it i stopped but
i got the bezel put on there from uh
from wifey wifey put the bells on
i got this my last birthday from gotti
i wanted this watch a lot too that's the
thing this is probably gonna be the next
watch i bought
but they bought it for me so you know i
really appreciate this one right here
yes yes rich i bought this from waffy
too
this is my first witch mufflers really
and had witches when i had this
you know i felt like i was one of the
first young [ __ ] for show
knocked up first but one of them at
shopboxes before my birthday
i had bunches for myself like 280.
bust down baguettes all around even on
the side
i could have busted a face down but even
the buckle bust down but yes
i could have busted the face down but
they said that's how you know they're
real
you leave the face clean so they just
know it's real
yeah 280. it's another presidential so i
i really got three of these just the
yellow girl present
i just this the watch i got before the
last watch i got
the last watch i got well this last one
i got before the last two watches i get
yeah this is the last prezi i got yellow
girl press
i seen my homeboy twin one of these when
i first got out
and i always wanted one so i had gary
make me one in detroit
and it's how it came out i guess i
really
wanted him to watch it i was really into
jury
as a whole and you know what i said i
just was
banned him as time ago and baby told me
like
start you like a crazy ass watch
collection
he's like you know i think you should do
that you know what i'm saying
i feel like this was somewhere to put my
money you know what i'm saying
i can invest in something like this i
feel like
washington should hold its value pretty
much
like hey watch i got them went up since
i bought them
so i feel like i did it right if i
wanted to sell them all you know what i
said of course i'm not going to sell
them but
if you get a regular
[Music]
my next watch probably gonna be the uh
probably gonna get the rose skeleton
give me a uh another richard
and that's probably going to be it yeah
i got everything i got the dweller big
diamond dude
i gave my homeboy i got some
about 10 watches thank you guys this is
supposed to do it for checking out my
dream collection i see you next time
appreciate the love